la bière est ce que c'est 100% vegan ou
pas la bière oui la bière 100 % vegan
l'aveyron certains industriels mettent
dans la bière de la colle de poisson une
substance gélatineuse recueilli des
vessies de poissons d'eau douce et ouais
ça on a on va prendre des trucs là je
vous dis moi j'ai appris des trucs quand
on le cuit la glace à la vanille 100%
légal ou pas non non non pas du tout me
suis dit non parce que la glace à la
vanille s'est souvent fait à base de
lait et donc le lait venant du merlan
que ça certains fabricants je vous jure
que c'est une vraie info de produits à
base de vanille utilise une sécrétion
annales du castor le castoréum qui est
utilisé comme un substitut de vanille
l'as rome est aussi utilisé dans les
yaourts ou des produits de boulangerie
sur la tête devant moi j'ai lu ça d'une
glace à la vanille mais c'est énorme et
c'est ouf
franchement de métier eu un jour l'idée
d'aller fouiller le cul d'un castor
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et moins cher mais c'est pour ça qu'on
voit ça coûte moins cher qu'il ya des
produits jeu les arômes de vanille ça
coûte très cher mais des produits
animaux partout parce que de toute façon
on tue des milliards d'animaux pour les
manger il reste des déchéances une
question d'oseille en fait tout on
maximise l'utilisation de ces déchets
par exemple la grèce ça devient de la
gélatine et c'est parce que de toute
façon ces déchets ils sont là les
nuggets croyez que c'est de la viande de
poulet lingettes szélesi les voyous
c'est tous les restes des poulets repris
fini sa langue est on met du colorant r
ça devient dur et c'est le cas pour le
jambon vous croyez que c'est rose
j'ai les jambes on voit ce que je suis
ce qu'elle gère en barral alors c'est
dur c'est pas complète flexitariens way
pardon mais ça c'est pas un pet
excitation mais moi c'est ce que je dis
non dans ce bouquin jeu l'objectif c'est
pas du tout de faire la morale aux gens
parce que un c'est insupportable ah oui
il fait c'est pas rien alexis t'as rien
ça consiste à réduire sa consommation de
produits animaux de l'ua de prêt sera
l'issue pour cent ans sans arrêter
totalement dans la superbe dedans mais
c'est déjà l'heure mois moi je vous dis
je confirme moitié je trouve que ça tu
veux flexity c'est vrai moi je suis le
rsa exige une réflexion c'est vrai la
raison j'ai bien aimé on a déjà
accompagné pour vous hein
cette fois j'ai une pensée pour tous
ceux qui regardent l'émission que son
resto en train de manger une glace
vanille qui se retrouvent sur blessure
de mon fils de cunac
[Applaudissements]
alors les siffler tortillas 100% vegan
ou pas non c'est 100% reagan et ça c'est
sans égal je vous préviens ouais ça
dépend à quoi parce que c'est
voilà je vous l'aï dit moi c'est ce que
je vois je trouve tout ça me rappelle la
portière dans le métier le dentifrice
100% vegan ou pas non non il ya des
saloperies de dentifrice vendus dans les
grandes surfaces ya de la gélatine de
khallouf ouais nan tu le savais ça ouais
non pour les marques en fait faut
vérifier d'où l'expression avoir une
haleine de porc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
savoir se bat et l'os premier degré a
foncé d'haleine de phoques
l'autre est à cheval sur les bases tu
vois dans les chais pas si on commence à
prod rapport pour un poc ou à quoi c'est
bon comme ça quoi
jusque là les bananes 100% dégâts nous
parle oui bien la wii u go non alors il
ya des débats les gares ou les oui oui
au sens légal du terme
oui mais effectivement la culture des
balades des manades ça implique de
d'éliminer un nombre d'un siècle charles
je crois que cette chance ce chic de
change non je veux pas dire de bêtises
je suis arrivé ceux qui sont devant 6
ans devant un ordi allez sur google mais
il semble que la laverie s'il ya
effectivement un insecte qui vit sur les
plans de bananes et côtiers éliminé pour
les halles tu mens mais qui va
s'éveiller sur les ballades cv gagnent
dans le sens où la wii la banane en soi
évidemment et wengen mais je vous le dis
les le spray vaporiser sur les bananes
leur permettant de retarder leur
maturation est réalisée à base de
chitosan il est fait à partir de ses
collègues depuis ce tracé que tu le
savais toi ça comme les crevettes les
crabes où les calmants je suis pour
toutes les religions à partir au moment
où ils croient en dieu les bécanes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]